[Music]
everybody welcome back to careful boys
we are returning
off the record we got a hot seat episode
hot seat somebody brand new that we are
lucky to have with us cinematographer
director and smash brothers enthusiast
and champion and undefeatable opponent
wow colleen lionheart hey hey you're an
eye okay and in hot seat fashion where
we like to turn up the heat let's start
it off cold and because bart's not here
in place of bert swan we're going to
have bert's
lawn
if i'm sitting in this chair we're not
going to do a cold question thank god
i'm not going to do no [ __ ] it
has to start cold this is why it's
called hot seat how many super smash
brothers championships do you have under
your belt zero
well that's pretty cold that's pretty
cool of course it depends though we've
had we've had sometimes we've made our
uh we've made tournaments up amongst
ourselves sure like are we talking like
all right i'll do it for borah all right
hold question my introduction
what is your most favorite office supply
office supply um that's a that's a cool
question that's cool my bad i i gotta
learn from that pen
a pen okay
like you know
yeah but you know like that really
really good pen there's always that one
specific pen that writes better than the
others yeah and then when you say give
me a pen and someone gives you one
that's not that you're like not this
right it's like the plastic like blue
one that you're like you never want no
not now i like the clicky ones i love
the clicker oh the clicky ones
multiple clicks yeah i like the one with
three colors
do you like those pens where there's
like different colors and you if you
click down a different i'm not a child
ryan yeah well
you just said we like that oh i just i
just oh man she just spit in our face
i'm a woman ryan i'm a woman women like
gelatins too oh yeah gel pens
my wife says love gel pens actually she
likes my wife does too she wants them
for her birthday and for christmas yeah
they always dry out you know that you've
used it to exhaustion
wow you caught me there interesting
the sparkly kind does everybody ever use
the curl quill pens where the ink has
the [ __ ] that's the pen i'm talking
about
i pluck it from a bird yeah and then can
we just talk about pens instead of doing
stupid hot seats
i just talk about kind of
writing utensils
that's supposed to be a cold question
guys they're supposed to end there okay
let's turn up the heat a little bit your
last name is lionheart is this correct
yeah okay where's the origin of your
last name where does it come from
the heart of a lion
so africa the savannah
you guessed it
you're lineage did you ever do a 23andme
um no i did ancestry.com i think and
what were your results um
mostly european get out me too
and then like banana 30
chinese
whoa really where did that come from
you got us excited you're like you are
part of this channel
like 30 is kind of high 50
mostly european you would be like yeah
i'll be 70 30. you know 30's pretty high
for chinese i was going to tell you i
did mine too and it said i was 99
chinese so that was really cool what a
surprise dude one percent european wow
i wish i got one percent of anything
else
but it just says unknown did you grow up
in la i did born and raised local wow i
rarely meet people in entertainment that
are actually local nobody says that
except for the locals right because we
also know locals i got to meet i got to
meet uh
captain kirks one time and he was a
local william shatner no no the new one
oh wait no the other oh captain kirk
chris pine huh i was outside
i was outside of an improv club and he
was like there and uh he knew my friend
and then i met him that way and he was
about to he was about to be kirk for the
first time but but i knew that he was
cast as him i was like oh [ __ ] you're
going to be captain kirk he's like yeah
man i was like oh that's kind of sick
and then yeah he was so is he from
glendale or what i don't know he's from
l.a and i thought that was crazy because
i met so many people in the industry
same [ __ ] and you can't believe when
they're actually from here i mean which
is strange because ellie's so vast true
because when you're actually from la you
never say you're from l.a you say you're
like
right you're like redondo beach or
whatever right
but when you leave la you go i'm from
l.a you don't say you're from west
covina so what part of la are you from
west hills
you're like where's that
i totally know where west hills
is the word interesting i barely know
where we are bro oh that place is not
what i expected
wait where is west hills it's next to
woodland hills oh and then the other
hills
okay i know that i know that area i know
that area that's the other valley
yeah this is the san gabriel valley yes
sgv baby
does anyone ever travel and go i'm from
sgb oh like travel to another country
yeah and then they ask you where you're
from you're like i should start they're
like where are you from
sgv
and they're like cool where's that
where's that that's the problem with
that that's why people just say you're
from l.a but like that's exactly why
because if i mean even in la they'll be
like where's west hills really it's like
dude how far do you want to have that
conversation with you exactly
there's like 30 cities here
i just want to keep it moving is it true
i mean dude the la people who talk about
freeways too much is that accurate or
what
i mean i i don't know like to be honest
i don't have a lot of la friends so i
personally don't talk about it because
it's it's a given it's a given like oh
really how'd you get here
yeah it was your route teleport
before
you want to know what the most uh you
know i like when you know someone's not
a local and they go oh interesting
you're from west halls you know what the
most uh if someone is a local local what
they would respond with is they always
tell you that's not l.a right
no matter what you [ __ ] say unless
you live in downtown it's just not their
part
yeah no matter what you're standing on
the [ __ ] home plate in dodger stadium
[Laughter]
that's not l.a if you're in the if
you're in the bleachers like you're not
in [ __ ] l.a real locals will always
respond
[ __ ] l.a
it doesn't matter what city you say
that's not a that's so true
you from [ __ ] honey to partly
that ain't l.a so what is the heart then
is it the financial district on [ __ ]
you know like perching square yeah
like what makes it the the main part you
know like the [ __ ] jewelry district
there's no consensus there's no like
consensus like oh that's like i'm in
skid row that's probably the heart of it
there you go that's the beating heart of
la and it spreads out
so you're in the industry and all that
right
is there something like an overarching
goal that you have not reached yet but
you're looking you're trying to
accomplish
yeah warmer um
yes and no like i have my like overall
achievements that i'd like to hit
mostly with my company um it being a
more creative agency that has its tiers
of directors and producers and editors
and and everybody within that
and that way i could just run the
company and then do the projects i'm
actually passionate about that would be
the success um
is it like a specific person or movie i
think
that will all be well and great but it's
it's not too specific enough um i think
it's more personal based with with the
company have you written anything like
you you've like uh well i'm not a writer
well oh what a coincidence because he is
uh-huh
he pulls out like 10 scripts
pick one please scripts and head shots
just dump them all over your phone
i brought my head shots too so
uh no but are you do you have something
like like any particular project where
you're like i one day i'm gonna make
that um
i think being
kind of like the female michael bay
would be great sick nice just because so
babe with an e yeah bae
[Laughter]
the way that he shoots [ __ ] where he
does that camera going in and out of
environments is so [ __ ] cool yeah i
just i have a love for movement i mean
it's hard you really like that if you're
being successful i think it's gay dude
i'm just joking i was like do you really
like it
i wanted her to like it then i crushed
it
why she touched the completely totally
dodged it i was like
like you know like that crane movement
and then it just i actually really do
love that i think it's [ __ ] tight
because he really brought that to a lot
of i mean everyone's ripping them off
now but but that was really cool okay
yeah there's so many filmmakers that do
talk [ __ ] about michael bay but i'm like
you ain't even doing movies so what are
you saying
yeah it's like you're calling yourself a
[ __ ] filmmaker i would kind of like
combine them though like i'd have more
of a like christopher nolan quinn
tarantino with the action of michael bay
so like you have like a death reaction
yeah you don't want like stunt fighters
who are just falling and tripping on
banana peels and [ __ ]
well that's actually the project i'm
working on right now
yeah yeah banana field too
directed by michael bay yeah
so action movies is your [ __ ] huh action
movies is your [ __ ] that's what i'm
transitioning to because dance was a
thing that i was very niche interesting
so you're going from dance to action
like fight choreo all that stuff oh wow
lisa you said you used to be an editor
yeah i've never seen that dream
you're just so polite
you're raised right
today's video is brought to you by
audible
dude i just recently realized that um
i am a audio learner than a reader
because
i have severe adhd and when i'm reading
um somehow i have to go back and read
the same damn page like 10 times because
after the second paragraph my mind
drifts off into another wonderland
and books take forever for me to read
and also i feel like
you know sometimes you want someone to
speak to you with a soothing voice
because you just feel like someone's
telling you like a teacher or something
yeah and then also
they fill up my mind with the words so i
can't talk in my own head and that
really helps me out a lot um and another
way that i've been using audible is at
the gym so before i would always use
music and all this stuff but now i've
been using podcasts or different kind of
educational books or whatever right
because in the morning i think i'm the
most alert
my mind is the most focused so when when
i'm at the gym
not only am i getting my muscle gains
i'm getting my brain gains
my favorite is when the audiobook is
read to me by the author oh yeah you
know there's more impact and feelings
yeah cause then you're like oh cool not
only is it just the words that they're
communicating but the tone and the
emotion and where they're coming from so
i really really like that and if you're
thinking audible is just for audiobooks
they got way more they got podcasts they
got comedy shows on there like their
goal is to be your one-stop shop for all
audio entertainment and what's cool is
that with this membership you get to
choose one title a month so you can
basically get one you know free book or
whatever and instead of buying it you
can spend that month listening and a lot
of these books are sometimes like four
or six hours long so
yeah a lot of them are like best sellers
so stuff that like can really help
improve your life so check it out so let
audible help you discover new ways to
laugh be inspired or be entertained new
members can try it for free for 30 days
visit audible.com off the record or text
off the record to 500 500 that's
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500 500. so try audible
for free for 30 days
audible.com off the record so so how did
you go from being editor to director um
she went she she moved her backwards to
forward that's wait wait here's a more
specific question
what's funny is i do do that because
that's the editor because literally all
editors [ __ ] do this right and then
directors they do this
yeah what does catering do
this
[ __ ] just takes it off
they're the ones eating it taste it they
gotta taste it make sure it's good
quality i feel like we should be doing
something
like the natural progression of you know
i started off editing and then
that kind of got lackluster and picked
up a camera and they wanted to shoot and
be part of the action and then
then you edit the call sheet
yeah
i've i've kind of done every job up to
the poi and i i'm still
learning as i go so i want to be a
director that actually has the tools to
direct not just somebody who is upheld
by their team would you say that being a
director it's like you have to know like
a little bit of what everyone does yeah
absolutely i think that's why it's taken
me much longer
i want to be the director that doesn't
know but he has a big vision and he's
just like you
come over here
do the flip there and then instead of
three times i want you to flip 10 times
now that's cool but i don't work here
i'm walking my dog no negativity
no negative no no
i don't care and then wardrobe come over
here make a coat right now in 30 seconds
yeah we're not i'm not doing wardrobe
this is my garage sale that's like the
misconception of a director you have to
be aggressive or loud or like you just
have to be this egotistical entitled oh
no you get the ad to do that yeah
absolutely
oh there's some directors too you don't
like directors that don't know the terms
and go like hey do the thingy with the
lens thing
make it make it look like that i like it
when the director's like um oh so he's
looking at there
how should we set this up
or i like the directors who don't say
anything and they're just kind of
standing around like
it's it's their project and then
everybody else is working around that oh
dude yeah
love that and then they just have their
name
as a credit i just want that chair
and then i want the i want the beret
with the horn and then be like yeah
yeah action
you want to be a star don't you
you'll never work in a city again we've
never reached the 12 minute and 47
second mark this is the part where we
like to really trim the heat let's get
real hot um
would you
would you say what would you say is the
most difficult thing the obstacle that
you have ever had and how did you
overcome it um i think just the
stereotype
i'm in a
typically more male driven field
i thought it was good because you're 30
asian
that too
yeah i don't see the chinese
if yeah you want it
because you're japanese you wouldn't see
it joe yeah or else my hate for you
would be strong
but
maybe it's only 30 hateful it's a male
driven feel yeah i mean because like
there are times where like i walked onto
my own set and they'd be like talent's
this way i don't know i'm like hi i
hired you
oh yeah they didn't know
and now i fired like somebody who is
like a grip or a gaffer who is like part
of the team that was required on that
production
and you know they're not doing it yeah
and that intent
um
but obviously you know the stereotype
does play a role it's kind of like that
that riddle where they go like the the
guy got in the car accident and the
doctor saved and then what happened oh
and it's like oh well he the doctor he
was this and that's like well the doctor
was a she
remember you know that riddle yeah yeah
yeah yeah like why could the doctor
operate yeah it's like oh well my brain
just automatically thought doctor was a
huge i think we're getting out of that
though so i thought the driver was a
woman for sure
i was like on the money i thought well
angelina jolie is like directing [ __ ] or
she was right for a minute yeah i'll
just yeah in the land of blood and honey
she did she did uh
i think that's it i mean there's a lot
of female dps out there that are killing
it too like they just you know what do
you think uh the director role has not
had many females in the role like do you
like
do you think girls just don't gravitate
to her or like what is what is it about
it could be like a natural like
psychology of just what women are
typically interested in what attracted
you to it what attracted me to it um i
just like
storytelling i enjoy
being able to
have a different perspective um and i
also just enjoy being able to um
tell people what to do absolutely
absolutely
absolutely what's your favorite movie
see i hate the word favorite top five
top five i love favorite
it sounded like a really tough one oh i
can't do it i can't do top five i can't
do top ten i can't top three top one
couple favorites just couple favorites
couple couples uh
yeah first things i mean [ __ ] but
they're not even gonna be my favorites
i'm gonna look back on this and be like
greece too
why did i say
i'll tell you like my few favorite
directors currently and i'll tell you
why instead of a favorite movie um i
like quentin tarantino just because when
you watch his movies you know it's his
movies he has he's like a director that
has a style a stamp to it um it helps
that he writes the majority of them so
top two quentin tarantino movies top one
quincy
kill bill
and
um
and gloria's fastest ah
good one okay top three
one more
once upon a time you know there are
things that i liked about things that i
didn't i hated it it was a little
did you as as being 30 chinese did you
not like the bruce lee part um
being 70 european i loved it
she played ratios yeah that's a good
answer that's a good [ __ ] it
overpowered
what did you think of tennant you know
what i tried watching that movie on a
plane ten minutes until i turned it off
what do you think it was turbulence
yeah my fear for my life
[Laughter]
this might be the end and i don't want
it to be watching this movie
dude i watched [ __ ] flight on an
airplane you try that [ __ ] out oh hell
yeah
i just couldn't get into it i don't know
what it was
do you have any major like regrets about
just
any of uh these life choices that you've
made no rag runs no rag
that's good
very tight very well handled very well
handled on a very difficult question
is that so like aside from like kind of
like dudes judging you or not judging
but just like like misjudging
or like
right or like or like or like people
like maybe like not expecting you to be
a director they just like get surprised
right has anyone like outwardly
disrespected you in the face where like
you just need to kick their nuts or
something yeah because they would be a
guy kick him in the [ __ ] face you
know or something not like a situation
that i can think of oh you've been
around pleasant people yeah i typically
have more control over the situations
i'm in especially nowadays so you're
choosing the
caster crew or whatever too yeah with
the i also choose my team michael so you
never had to fire anybody on set before
no i'm tough on fire i think i'm a
pretty good judge of character like the
people that i work with
they love what they do and they just
want to be there to add value they're
actual team players nobody has an ego
um
so yeah i don't think i'm a good example
of somebody who's dealt with a lot of
situation like hollywood have you ever
been not paid
um
no wow because i'm i'm super diligent on
my contracts i write my own contracts so
you just like preemptively doing
everything to protect so then you don't
run into situations well it's like
shitty luck like i don't like don't
believe in luck because luck is just
preparation so if you prepare enough to
to make the situation what you want it
to be
then you're gonna be okay for the most
part i mean you're always gonna run into
situations on productions where things
are gonna go wrong but
i think that only happened once where
nothing went wrong on set like we
weren't going over time like there were
any electrical issues like the location
manager wasn't being a dick like and i
was like
what is happening right now something
has to go wrong
um but with my interaction with people
no they've been
decently pleasant
um on the crew and talent side i would
say it's more so with clients
i got i got a i got a more hot question
has it affected your love life being in
such a powerful position hmm that's good
um
i don't know
can't we yeah go ahead so they're all
ex-boyfriends meaning like meaning i'm
not currently with somebody did that
ever what does that mean it intimidates
them get in the like the no because i
think the people that i've always been
associated with in that way were always
also in the entertainment world so they
understood it
i think that's a key component to having
even
a chance at a successful relationship
yeah because they understand the field
that you're in um so you're against nine
to five guys not against it i just
haven't found somebody interesting
enough
wow just think those regular joes are
kind of schmoes a little bit yeah yeah a
bunch of [ __ ] losers be more
interesting that's gonna be more
interesting stuff don't work at nine to
five
try ten to six yeah
eight to three like more never let them
know your next move get a better job
just get a better job yeah just don't
work just don't work so most of the past
relationships you've had were like in
entertainment so they already had that
understanding of your career and then so
schedules and things like that never
became an issue like for most people
that they kind of like outside the
industry so then like
would it just be like normal couple
fights and stuff just like or would it
be like
like i wanna [ __ ] do this film no i
wanna do this film you compete because
you're like with another director or
something
no you never i'm just trying to find
drama god damn it you know there's got
to be like something spicy your life is
like [ __ ] so good like damn you're
just not asking the right questions
what's the dramatic question yeah can
you just give it to us then can you talk
[ __ ] about catherine bigelow or
something like that yeah yeah [ __ ] on
catherine bigelow you take a [ __ ] on a
big show on kathleen bigelow oh yeah
who's your competition yeah who do you
hate in the industry exactly yeah who
you're who's your competition you want
to switch female directors like that
[ __ ] to [ __ ] do it i will say this
so um
my website it used to be lionheart
creative.net [ __ ] my life it was that
because um
out of just
bad intentions this person
knew that i was naming my company
lionheart creative and bought the domain
names
and it's selling lionheart creative.com
for like almost three thousand dollars
so now it's now it's lionheart
creative.com but um yeah i've had.net
for quite a while because of that
bam so this was the person you used to
work with
yeah let's [ __ ] punch him in the face
let's jump this [ __ ] dude at
least you know the identity i mean it
could only be one person
it could only be one
[Laughter]
last question what do you think about
the highlander series oh my god
your favorite one and why is it number
two
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you